I didn't thank Kathleen for a question
but I do now and Josh thanks for yours
too there's a whole spectrum in this
regard Joshua the clothes at home I
would say a project like this and
religion and ecology in a science-based
institution Forestry and environmental
studies this is a is an issue we're the
only humanities professors at forestry
environmental studies and it's so
especially when we first came if you a
little marginal and it takes a while to
convince people because to think of
religion right away and even Neil tease
me says you sound like a preacher to
bring someone who has an understanding
that anyone who speaks from religion
speaks of necessarily from a theological
position and obviously this project is
trying to foreground history of
religions or the academic study of
religion and there is a theological
perspective on these issues which i
think eco theology is a very appropriate
a study from a particular tradition as
most of the people in the film I would
say eco theology but whereas maryville
and I are as historians of religion
coming at it from the standpoint of the
academic study of religion but still
even close to home it's very difficult
for a scientist say scientists who are
new atheists who have a particular
reading of religion and it's totally
problematic in terms of the human
species even to consider religion in
terms of our mental formation so yes
there are some some issues that have to
be considered there what we try to do
until a out the motivational
characteristic also I think Neil's
comment earlier about what religion
brings in this variety of hopes is very
related to the religion and ecology
project in another part of the spectrum
Josh I think it's very interesting to
just report out to you that this is a
project on the Yamuna River is a
culmination of over three years of work
on the ground I think you're all aware
that rajendra pachauri the head of the
IPCC the Intergovernmental Panel on
Climate Change Nobel Prize winner for
the panel has been at Yale now two weeks
every month because he heads the climate
Institute so we have engaged pachauri or
patchy as he's affectionately called
we've engaged him to bring him into
awareness of this project because he
heads Terry institute of which terror
university is apart so he's on board he
finds this is a very significant project
to bringing religious leaders of
pilgrimage sites in to make an exchange
so when these leaders talk about the
yamuna they have data now they don't
just point to the river it's polluted or
it's this and that they now begin to
have real data and scientists begin to
say these are religious leaders who are
literally talking about water
conservation water story to
reforestation catchment areas and Daniel
serious projects that could take place
on getting them preaching again but here
Josh here's the real kicker for me a
year and a half ago when the project was
firmed up on the ground date set people
beginning to sign on board coming we
made a wish list of invites and on that
wish list we reached into the government
as far as Ramesh jayram Ramesh the new
environmental sir who's first rate
really fine Minister of the Environment
in India and the two ministries most
involved with the Yamuna River of
Ministry of Forestry and the environment
and the Pollution Control Board in Delhi
there's the really important ones there
has been for over a decade a young
interaction plan over
five hundred million dollars thrown at
the Yamuna River especially in the deli
segment they Sigmund ties the Yemen a
river according to its pollution and
Delhi is just as I mentioned it's
eutrophic it's all industrial waste and
human waste so this young man action
plan has totally failed the river is
worse now than it was when the project
began so everyone's trying to find a way
how to think about this when we sent
this invitation list two ministries of
Forestry and environmental studies and
the Pollution Control Board the response
was very quick we will not come we will
not come to a discussion that where
religion is involved because it will do
it will have no effect it will just be
more blather and talk and nothing will
be accomplished so this cynicism that we
encountered was very very interesting we
simply pulled back in other words
there's no sense at this point to try
and bring on board people who have a
very negative attitude we have very
positive participation from the religion
side we have very positive participation
from the science at you you'd be amazed
to hear the scientists that we're
engaging the first days of discussion
very high level science with regard to
what are the what are the readings what
are the scientifically the second and
third days these are people who are
talking about what listen I go to a
temple and we never talk about these
things at this shy by temple that I'm
part of it I I think we should know
their they have their own religious
positions which they keep bracketed so
josh is is a ongoing and penetrating
question